why is the smartphone worth sixteen
hundred dollars is it because of the
true 4k oled display that's now 50
brighter or the dual front-facing
speakers that have way more bass or how
about the new camera system that shoots
4k 120 frames per second video on all
the lenses or for the first time ever a
true optical zoom camera or maybe all of
the creative focused software built in
or possibly just this headphone jack
that is now really hard to come by well
today we are going to put the sony
xperia 1 4 to the test against the
iphone 13 pro to see how it stacks up at
1600
compared to 9.99 now i know you guys are
thinking why are you not comparing it to
the 13 pro max well i have to say that
the comfort of this phone in the size
compares way more to the iphone 13 pro
putting them face to face the sony is
actually slightly slimmer than the
iphone even though
you get much more screen space at least
vertically and not only that even though
this is a larger phone uh as far as the
weight the sony is about 10
lighter than the iphone both of them do
have this kind of square edge design but
the sony has this little bevel all
around so you get actually the benefits
of having that nice grip from that flat
edge but also a little bit more comfort
than the iphone i have to say this sony
xperia one mark iv is one of the most
comfortable phones to hold in the hand i
also like how clean the sony looks on
the back we have just the sony and the
xperia logo we don't have a bunch of
text and serial numbers just like the
iphone looks nice we also have that
little nfc logo because sony does use
that especially on their uh cameras it
makes it easy to connect and as far as
the sides on this left hand side we have
no buttons at all like we do on our
iphone flipping over to the other side
we have our volume rocker at the top and
then below that we have a recessed power
button that is also a fingerprint
scanner and then even lower we have a
dedicated shutter button when you're
using this phone as a camera which is
quite nice now at the bottom we have a
usb type-c instead of lightning and we
also have this little slot which is
really cool that doesn't really need a
little pin remover tool you can actually
just get your fingerprint underneath
pull it out and this not only gives you
access to your sim it also gives you a
micro sd card which actually goes up to
one terabyte in space so sony definitely
wants you to shoot a ton of photos and
video on this phone
and with that this one actually comes
with 512 gigabytes of storage built in
internally and we also get 12 gigabytes
of ram compared to 6 on the iphone so
now we're starting to see why it's
priced so high comparing the front of
the phones there's a different setup the
sony doesn't have that notch sticking
out but it has that big forehead and
chin like a traditional phone with ultra
slim bezels compared to the iphone as
thicker ones but they're even all around
now sony sticks with this setup even now
because they care about their speakers
as dual front-facing stereo speakers so
with that said let's go ahead and see if
that trade-off was worth it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys let me know what you
think honestly i was surprised when i
heard the difference the sony has those
dual front-facing speakers they say it's
a big improvement but the iphone even
the smaller one that's quieter the
regular pro sounds a lot better i mean
listen to this
and then
not only is it louder on the iphone it
has much deeper bass and yes i did go
through all the settings i enabled dolby
i found the best mix of options and it
still doesn't really compete with the
iphone now with that i also have to give
props to the headphone jack not only
does it have one an iphone doesn't it
actually plays back hd audio with a
bunch of different codecs that are
supported and if you guys didn't know
there are still people out there that
are buying brand new walkmans this one
for example is 350 bucks with great
reviews just for the sake of being able
to play hd audio for high quality
listening they actually have something
to go up to 3
200
so if you're an audio file you're in
that creative music space that feature
really stands out and now let's compare
the displays first off we have that form
factor difference the sony is a 21x9
ultra wide display and holding it up
between portraits you guys can see that
there's actually more things visible on
the screen now the formatting is a
little bit different so i actually see
more width even though the phone is
slightly slimmer and i see extra content
on the bottom now both these phones do
support 120 hertz for ultra smoothness
and as far as detail the iphone is 460
ppi nice and sharp but the sony is
643 i believe that is 40
more pixels on the sony but can you tell
a difference even about a photo way
looking pretty closely to the phone
honestly i cannot text is super sharp
and clear on both phones now how about
for video
this phone has that 21x9
aspect ratio is perfect for watching 4k
video with no bars let's go ahead and
open it up and take a look taking a look
at this 4k hdr spider-man clip we see
one that the full screen is filled up on
the sony because the aspect ratio
matches most movies where the iphone
it's not filled up of course we can go
ahead and zoom in then we still have
some bars at the top and then we have
our notch cutting into the video as well
now apart from that both are streaming
4k even though the iphone doesn't have a
4k screen you can still over sample
and what i've noticed so far watching is
that the performance of the oled screen
the sony the highlights actually pop a
little bit more than the iphone does
which is actually great because the
iphone is really really good at hdr
playback sony is really proud of their
processing engine and software with this
phone they say that it's similar to the
algorithms on their high-end tvs and
that makes the video look good and i
would say it actually does look good has
a little bit more contrast in its
profile highlights really pop slightly
more saturation and overall if you are
going to be watching a lot of videos or
movies specifically on your phone it
does do a really good job now that is
interesting because the actual
brightness of the screens have a much
bigger difference so here i have the
sony maxed out completely we have a
normal page right here and then if i go
and i adjust the iphone you see how much
brighter it is we'll adjust that camera
angle so you guys could see that
difference and the iphone is at roughly
1200 nits compared to about 800 on the
sony so that 50
brighter still doesn't mean that it
matches up for outdoor brightness or
even indoors if you want to max it out
so that just makes me suspect that sony
is limiting the total brightness
probably because of battery life because
as a 4k screen super high resolution
plus super brightness means lots of
battery drain now it does have a 5 000
milliamp hour battery to help out but
that still isn't a ton considering
everything else that's built in in that
screen now before we jump into
performance i want to give a shout out
to the cameras we are going to dive in
detail tomorrow with a blind camera
comparison checking out if these new
sensors
new lenses can actually compete with the
iphone in their software they've built
up so make sure you guys hit that
subscribe button if you want to see a
very fun entertaining video with vadim
and angelica and myself and just have a
lot of fun with us and seeing the
difference in them with that said let's
go ahead and jump into the performance
the first test i'm running is
speedometer 2.0 which is going to test
the responsiveness of the phone
now this sony has the latest snapdragon
8 gen 1 chip the best of the best the
iphone has of course the a15 now
unfortunately some of the applications
that we'd normally benchmark with
hands-on they won't let me install it
because this phone is pre-released and
they don't want that leaking online but
we do know that this phone has good
cooling just like the samsung s22 ultra
and the performance is gonna be very
similar and look at that we have 324
compared to
107. now of course that's because of the
single performance apple's way ahead
also software we have safari versus
chrome that's the default browser here
and then all the other ui layers and
other things in the background that kind
of slow it down and i have noticed that
the iphone is way snappier in regular
use now as far as geekbench 5 the a15 is
38 faster than the new snapdragon both
in single core and in multi-core now
that isn't even a one generation gap in
fact the iphone 11
is actually faster than in single core
and almost as fast in multi-core
compared to this latest chip that
recently came out so as far as cp
performance and even software the iphone
is definitely ahead now with graphics
the difference is about 18
in 3d marks wildlife extreme test so
apple's chip and qualcomm snapdragon in
the sony phone they've gotten a lot
better in graphics this year and they
are much closer now with that said the
iphone does dim it has a lot of heating
issues if you're playing high resolution
for a while whereas the sony has better
thermal management so if you're playing
for a while that difference can actually
kind of get closed and that leads me to
software because sony has done so many
improvements and optimizations and
created software like game enhancer
where it will give you so many different
options for example you can live stream
to youtube with your phone
just with it and not only will you
actually stream it can record it can
show comments and with that they give
you a ton of settings for example you
can change your game mode if you want to
you know get better battery life
you can actually go in and change your
display settings so for microphone you
can equalize the audio so if you want
say footsteps to stand out more and you
want to lower the high end frequencies
for competitive gaming you can do that
you can go to image quality and you can
literally raise the shadows if you want
to see better in dark conditions that
will improve your gameplay there's just
so much more things you could do
it's just really really nice for people
that are serious about their games now
that is only the beginning we have our
video pro app let me go ahead and allow
all of this here um that really gives
you so many options if you care about
getting the best video you have all of
your information alongside the bottom
that you can manually change you have
your levels you can zoom you can
manually focus you get object tracking
white balance you can just change so
many different things your aspect ratio
you can shoot in 21 by nine it is crazy
what sony gives it's just like an actual
real camera of course for a photo we
also have a ton of options on the photo
side and of course we talked about their
live streaming setup not only can you
live stream from any of the cameras
without any extra apps directly to
youtube or other platforms you can have
a little vlogging setup and you'll have
a screen on the back if you want to
record and see yourself with the back
camera
or you can plug a camera with a usbc
cable for those are supported or through
a card directly into the actual phone
and you'll live stream without any
computer or laptop to wherever you want
with a slim package and that is just
crazy for people that do professional
video not only that when i was shooting
a ton of video commercial stuff i wanted
to have a slim high quality display to
use as an external monitor most on the
market was 720p or 1080p poor battery
life really huge and thick and heavy so
you can use this as a companion to your
camera with a true 4k display to be able
to use as a monitor outside and that
just provides you so much value
now with all of that said there's so
much packed into this and we're going to
take a look at the cameras tomorrow in
the blind camera comparison to see if
it's truly as good as sony says um not
everybody really needs that so sony
knows and they actually are saying hey
this is marketed for creatives those
that care about entertainment gaming
live streaming video and photography
that is who they're marketing it to all
the creative kind of people that are
willing to spend more money whereas the
iphone is marketed to everybody it's an
all-around phone without all the special
features for the music producers things
like that so that's why i want to hear
your guys's opinion do you think this
phone is worth it from what you've seen
or would you just go with an iphone do
you not really care about all those
extra features in the software you guys
let me know down below
personally i think if you can use some
of those extra features if you are going
to use the voice recording features they
have ai denoising the gaming stuff
especially the streaming if you have a
camera that you want to combine this
phone with it does provide a really good
value with the amount of storage that is
built in uh so you guys let me know your
thoughts click that circle above if you
guys want to subscribe help us reach our
goal of one million subscribers and you
want to see the comparison check out one
of those great videos right over there
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]